A quick warning, there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of this show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
简短的预警，今天的节目中包含未经消音的脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，可以访问我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。
From WBEZ Chicago, This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Raise your hand if you are in Georgia, ready to start curing ballots and fight for every vote.
在佐治亚州，准备好开始处理选票并为每一张选票而战的人，请举手。
1:00 PM Wednesday, the day after the election-- Democrat volunteer Kim Hood runs a training on Zoom for 500 other Democrat volunteers who are going to go out and cure ballots in Georgia. "Cure" means tracking down voters whose mail-in ballots had a problem with the signature or whatever, and they've been rejected so they don't count. Curing is the word they use for fixing the ballots. Another word you hear a lot-- "rescuing."
周三下午1点，选举日过后的第二天——民主党志愿者金·胡德（Kim Hood）在 Zoom 上为另外500名准备去佐治亚州处理选票的民主党志愿者进行培训。“处理”（Cure）是指追踪那些因签名或其他问题而被拒收、导致无效的邮寄选票。处理是他们修复选票时使用的词。你还会经常听到另一个词——“拯救”。
All eyes in this country are on Georgia right now. Everybody, shake it off. Get rid of that excess energy and all those nerves. We're about to channel it. Normally, this is a super polished training, but it is-- I have not been to sleep.
现在全国的目光都聚焦在佐治亚州。大家，抖抖身体。甩掉多余的精力和所有的紧张感。我们正要引导它。通常，这是一场准备充分的培训，但是——我还没睡过觉。
You can see how they could feel like all of this could come down to them. In Georgia, it was so close-- so close all week-- between the president and Joe Biden. Out of nearly 5 million votes cast, at times, the candidates were just 1,100 votes apart. And the trainers explain to the group that there are over 5,000 votes out there that they can cure, mail-in ballots and provisional ballots. So after the training, people fan out, get on phones, knock on doors.
你可以看出他们如何感到这一切都可能取决于他们。在佐治亚州，竞争非常激烈——整个星期都非常激烈——在总统和乔·拜登之间。在近500万张选票中，有时两位候选人之间仅有1100票的差距。培训师向团队解释说，还有超过5000张选票可以处理，包括邮寄选票和临时选票。因此，培训结束后，人们四散开来，拨打电话，敲响家门。
Hi. Is Trevor home?
你好，特雷弗（Trevor）在家吗？
Trevor is at college, the woman says. It's Wednesday night in the Atlanta suburbs. Marla Cureton is the volunteer who stopped by to find Trevor.
那名女子说特雷弗在上大学。这是亚特兰大郊区的周三晚上。玛拉·库雷顿（Marla Cureton）是过来寻找特雷弗的志愿者。
Oh, OK. He came up on a rejected absentee ballot list. And so we're just tracking down and seeing that people are able to resolve their--
哦，好的。他的名字出现在被拒收的缺席选票名单上。所以我们正在追踪，看看人们是否能够解决他们的——
"So his vote's not counted?" the woman at the door says.
“所以他的票没有被计算在内？”门口的女子说。
Well, it's not over yet. He has until Friday at 6:00 to cure his ballot.
嗯，还没有结束。他有时间在周五6点前处理他的选票。
Marla gives her a packet of materials and explains he basically just has to sign an affidavit and photograph that and his photo ID and email them into the county. Back in the car, Marla describes how she ended up deciding to volunteer for this after seeing President Trump win so many voters, state after state, just the night before on election night.
玛拉给了她一包资料，并解释说他基本上只需要签署一份宣誓书，将该文件和他的带照片身份证件拍照，然后通过电子邮件发送给县里即可。回到车里，玛拉描述了她在前一天选举之夜看到特朗普总统在州与州之间赢得那么多选民后，是如何决定为此做志愿者的。
A lot of us women of color, African-American women like myself, had a lot of anger to express this morning. Even when we realized, we were like, we think Biden is going to pull this out. We believe this. But my god, it shouldn't have been this close. And what does that say? And there is a lot of anger to get out about that. And a lot of the women who are white allies also, it's just like, we were just, in our hearts, we realized we never thought it would be this close. But by the time noon and 1:00 PM came around, it's like, OK, we'll come back to that later. We've got to get these votes.
我们很多有色人种女性，像我这样的非裔美国女性，今天早上有很多愤怒需要表达。即使当我们意识到，我们觉得拜登会赢。我们相信这一点。但是天哪，本不应该这么接近的。那说明了什么？关于这一点，有很多愤怒需要发泄。许多白人盟友女性也一样，我们只是在心里意识到，我们从没想过会这么接近。但到了中午和下午1点，就像是，好吧，我们稍后再谈这个。我们得拿到这些选票。
It's tedious work. A volunteer named Erika Meyer who's doing this by phone told me that, in her three-hour shift on Wednesday, she reached maybe one person for every 10 calls she made.
这是枯燥的工作。一位名叫埃里卡·迈耶（Erika Meyer）的志愿者在电话中告诉我，周三她那三个小时的班里，每打10个电话，她可能才联系上一个人。
It's definitely mostly voicemails.
大部分肯定都是语音留言。
How many ballots did you fix?
你修复了多少张选票？
Five.
五张。
In three hours?
三个小时里？
Yeah. It's not a very big return on investment.
是啊。投资回报率不是很高。
How do you feel about that? Does it feel like just a drop in the ocean? Do you feel like-- does it feel important?
你对此有何感想？感觉就像大海里的一滴水吗？你觉得——这感觉重要吗？
I kind of swing back and forth on a pendulum of political despair. [LAUGHS] Sometimes it feels like-- especially if I have a successful conversation with a voter, then you're like, yes! That was so great. Then you kind of ride that high for a little while. But when I look at the clock and see how much time all these calls have taken, and this-- yeah, as you say, a drop in the ocean.
我有点在政治绝望的钟摆上来回摆动。[笑] 有时感觉就像——特别是在我与选民成功对话后，你就会想，太好了！那太棒了。然后你会沉浸在那阵兴奋中一会儿。但当我看到时钟，看到所有这些电话花了多少时间，而这——正如你所说，大海里的一滴水。
So there's a big Zoom training that the Democrats did in Georgia today for volunteers curing votes. And during that training, they said that before you help the voter, be sure the voter is voting for the Democrats. Were you told that in your training?
今天佐治亚州的民主党人为处理选票的志愿者进行了一次大型 Zoom 培训。在培训期间，他们说在帮助选民之前，要确保选民是投给民主党的。你们的培训中有这样说吗？
I don't recall hearing that. But I do know that in our script, one of the first questions is, were you supporting Democrats on your ballot?
我不记得听过那个。但我确实知道，在我们的剧本中，第一个问题之一是，你在选票上支持民主党吗？
And if they say no, are you supposed to hang up?
如果他们说不，你们应该挂断吗？
Thank them for their time and hang up, yeah.
感谢他们的时间然后挂断，是的。
Would you be able to do it? You know what I mean? It's like-- really, there's no pretense that this is about democracy and counting every ballot. At that point, it's just about winning.
你做得到吗？你明白我的意思吗？就像——真的，没有任何关于这是为了民主和清点每一张选票的假象。在那一点上，这只是为了赢。
I mean, if somebody said I voted for Trump, but I'm really disappointed that my vote isn't going to count, I couldn't sleep at night if I knew that I had suppressed their vote.
我是说，如果有人说我投给了特朗普，但我很失望我的票没被计算在内，如果我知道我压制了他们的选票，我晚上会睡不着觉的。
So you would help them.
所以你会帮助他们。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah?
是吗？
We can't say we want it and then not do it.
我们不能说我们想要它，然后又不去做。
Have you had to do that?
你必须那样做过吗？
Well, I had one person yell at me, "Trump 2020," and then hang up, so I didn't have to do it. [CHUCKLES]
嗯，有一个人对我大喊“特朗普2020”，然后挂断了电话，所以我没必要那样做。[轻笑]
Well, today on our program-- after an election week full of uncertainty, even after news organizations looked at the results and called the election for Joe Biden, there's still MORE uncertainty. President Trump has not conceded, he's called the vote counts fraudulent, so today we have stories of people all over the country living through this weird-- I don't know what to call it-- gravityless limbo of uncertainty that we have all been floating through since Tuesday. Speaking for myself, checking the news compulsively.
今天我们的节目——在充满不确定性的一周选举后，即使在新闻机构查看结果并宣布乔·拜登赢得选举后，仍然有更多的不确定性。特朗普总统没有承认失败，他称选票统计存在欺诈，所以今天我们有全国各地的人们讲述他们经历这种奇怪的——我不知道该怎么称呼它——自周二以来我们一直在漂浮的那种失重的、不确定的虚空。就我个人而言，强迫性地查看新闻。
The Washington Post called the day after the election this Wednesday "a hump day for the ages." All of us wondering, how is this going to end? Our fellow citizens going through that. Stay with us.
《华盛顿邮报》将选举后的周三称为“史上的周三”。我们都在想，这会如何结束？我们的同胞正在经历这一切。请继续关注。
Act One, Virginia. So Mike Giglio is a reporter who's been following militia groups for the last year, interviewing the men in them, including lots of guys who've been bracing for civil war. Over the last few weeks, when President Trump repeatedly encouraged his supporters to go to polling stations and, quote, "watch very carefully on Election Day," Mike wondered if any of these groups and those guys he knew would heed the call. Here's Mike.
第一幕，弗吉尼亚州。迈克·吉格里奥（Mike Giglio）是一位追踪民兵组织的记者，过去一年里一直在采访其中的成员，包括许多为内战做准备的人。过去几周，当特朗普总统反复鼓励支持者去投票站，引用：“在选举日仔细观察”时，迈克想知道这些组织和他认识的那些人是否会听从召唤。这是迈克的故事。
When I called Joe Klemm, the leader of a militia in Virginia called the Ridge Runners, he told me that's exactly what they were getting ready to do. So I joined them for a pre-election training session in the Appalachian Mountains one chilly Saturday morning three weeks ago. Joe wouldn't tell me the location over the phone, so I met him and about a dozen other guys in camo at a McDonald's and followed them to a large farm. They start the day standing at attention behind an abandoned building with their AR-15s.
当我打电话给民兵组织“山脊奔跑者”（Ridge Runners）的领导人乔·克莱姆（Joe Klemm）时，他告诉我这就是他们准备要做的事情。因此，三周前一个寒冷的周六早晨，我在阿巴拉契亚山脉参加了他们的选前训练。乔在电话里不愿告诉我地点，所以我和一个大约十几名穿着迷彩服的人在麦当劳会合，跟着他们到了一个大农场。他们的一天是从站在废弃建筑后用AR-15步枪立正开始的。
Parade rest! Morning, gents. Glad to see you all here. Thank you all for coming out. Just real quick, we're going to go over a couple of things today.
立正！早上好，先生们。很高兴见到你们。谢谢大家前来。简短地说，我们今天要讨论几件事。
That's Joe. He's a muscular 29-year-old who looks exactly like the former Marine sergeant he tells me he is.
那是乔。他是一个肌肉发达的29岁年轻人，看起来和他说自己曾是海军陆战队军士长的形象完全吻合。
Just want to kind of bring this all to the forefront of all of your minds with the election on the way. We will need to stay vigilant. Right now, we're all-- I've been collaborating with a lot of the other group commanders in the area. Each group is going to have a set number of polling sites that we're going to be responsible for. Each polling site is going to have two, hopefully three, gray men operating at that site.
随着选举的到来，我想把这带到你们每个人的脑海中。我们需要保持警惕。现在，我们都——我一直在与该地区许多其他小组指挥官进行协作。每个小组将负责一定数量的投票点。每个投票点将有两名，希望是三名“灰人”在该站点运作。
Gray men-- that means men in plainclothes trying to blend into the crowds at the polling stations. Joe tells me what they're looking for is groups like Black Lives Matter and Antifa, who they believe could disrupt the election, intimidate voters, or commit fraud. They get this from the president. Trump and right-wing media have been raising these fears without evidence for months.
灰人——这意味着身穿便服试图融入投票站人群的人。乔告诉我就要寻找像“黑人的命也是命”和“反法西斯主义者”这样的组织，他们认为这些组织可能会扰乱选举、恐吓选民或进行欺诈。他们从总统那里得到这些信息。几个月来，特朗普和右翼媒体一直在没有证据的情况下散布这些恐惧。
Everyone in Joe's militia is white. The question of whether militias are synonymous with white nationalists always comes up with groups like this, and they almost always reject that label. All of the places that Joe imagines might be hotspots on Election Day are nearby cities with lots of people of color. But he and his members insist they're not racist.
乔民兵组织里的每个人都是白人。关于民兵是否等同于白人民族主义者的问题总是出现在这样的组织中，而他们几乎总是拒绝那个标签。乔认为选举日可能是热点的所有地方都是附近有许多有色人种的城市。但他和成员坚称他们不是种族主义者。
Before January, when Joe started the group, most of these guys didn't know each other. Joe's one the most intense people I've met in the militias. And when he talks, people tend to snap to attention. He tells me stories about fighting as a black ops soldier and losing friends and killing enemies. I check with the Marines, and they tell me they have no record of his service. Joe claims that's because it's classified.
一月之前，当乔开始组建这个小组时，这些人大多数互不相识。乔是我在民兵组织中见过的最激烈的人之一。当他说话时，人们倾向于立刻立正。他告诉我他在作为特种作战士兵战斗并失去朋友和杀死敌人的故事。我向海军陆战队核实，他们告诉我没有他的服役记录。乔声称这是因为那是机密。
When I ask people what drew them to the group, they talk about Joe, his charisma. Here's a member called Savage.
当我问人们是什么吸引他们加入这个小组时，他们谈到了乔，他的魅力。这是名叫“萨维奇”（Savage）的一名成员。
I went to a muster in Whitesville for a group. And that group just basically wanted to stand around and talk. And there's nothing wrong with that. But don't call yourself a militia if you just want to stand around and talk politics. Joe's group, when he came up and delivered his thing, they talked about training. And I mean, who don't want to get out and shoot rounds downrange for fun? You know? Who doesn't want to train and be a part of something?
我去参加了怀特斯维尔的一个小组集合。那个小组基本上只是想站着聊天。这没什么错。但如果你只是想站着谈论政治，就别称自己为民兵。乔的小组，当他过来发表言论时，他们谈论的是训练。我的意思是，谁不想出去为了乐趣打靶练习？你知道吗？谁不想训练并成为某件事的一部分？
A lot of the day, it seems like the guys are just here to bond and have fun. Joe leads the men through six hours of drills, starting with the PT and then moving to shooting positions and room clearing.
这一天的大部分时间，看起来这些人只是为了联络感情和玩乐。乔带领他们进行了六个小时的演习，从体能训练开始，然后转移到射击位置和清理房间。
So, it's initial contact. So, contact front, 200 meters.
所以，这是最初接触。接触正面，200米。
Contact front, 200 meters.
接触正面，200米。
Bang, bang, bang.
砰，砰，砰。
Bang.
砰。
Bang. Moving!
砰。移动！
Move!
移动！
They're running a drill here where the idea is that they learn how to cover each other. When I spend time with these groups, I'm always wondering how seriously they take the idea that they might really engage in violence. On the one hand, they're giving each other nicknames, slapping each other on the back, and saying, "bang."
他们在这里进行演习，理念是学习如何掩护彼此。当我和这些组织在一起时，我总是想知道他们对自己可能真的参与暴力的想法有多认真。一方面，他们给彼此起绰号，拍拍对方的背，说着“砰”。
But at the same time, they really do believe the country's in danger, that they might need to turn their guns on their fellow citizens one day. And they buy into all the unsupported claims Trump makes about liberals bent on election fraud and violence and the need to stop them. And they think they're the ones to do it.
但同时，他们确实相信国家处于危险之中，有一天可能需要将枪口对准同胞。他们全盘接受特朗普关于自由派蓄意选举欺诈和暴力的未经证实的说法，以及阻止他们的必要性。他们认为他们就是去做这件事的人。
Nearly all the militiamen I've spoken to this year believe that Democrats committed massive voter fraud in 2016, and they've been doing it again this year with mail-in ballots and early voting. Joe is worried the 2020 election could be stolen.
我今年采访过的几乎所有民兵成员都相信民主党在2016年进行了大规模选民欺诈，而且今年他们通过邮寄选票和提前投票再次这样做。乔担心2020年选举可能会被窃取。
Did it matter to you that Trump said that?
特朗普说的话对你有影响吗？
Well, yeah, of course it did. Because considering all the access to information that he has that we don't, if he's dropping these little tidbits, there's something that people like me need to pay attention to.
嗯，是的，当然有。因为考虑到他拥有的所有我们没有的信息渠道，如果他透露这些小道消息，那说明像我这样的人需要关注。
So you think that he's basing that on real information?
所以你认为他是基于真实信息吗？
I do.
我是这么认为的。
You think it's possible that he's playing politics?
你觉得他是在耍政治手腕的可能性吗？
I don't think so. He seems like more of a straightforward kind of guy. I think that he's not the type of person to play politics.
我不这么认为。他看起来更像是一个直截了当的人。我认为他不是那种会耍政治手腕的人。
Sometimes I wish the people in these militia groups could hear how much they sound like people I've covered in countries that have come undone. I spent a lot of time in Eastern Ukraine in early 2013 with the pro-Russian activists who eventually plunged the region into a war.
有时我希望这些民兵组织的人能听到他们听起来有多像我报道过的那些走向崩溃的国家的人。2013年初，我在乌克兰东部花了很多时间与亲俄激进分子在一起，他们最终将该地区推入了战争。
They would go on social media and tune into Russian propaganda and convince themselves that their countrymen were out to destroy them. They'd tell me that bands of Nazis were coming from Kiev to kill them. I was struck by the way people had to convince themselves that the other side was absolutely out to get them, was bent on their destruction in order to take that step into real violence.
他们会在社交媒体上关注俄罗斯宣传，并说服自己他们的同胞要摧毁他们。他们告诉我纳粹团伙正从基辅赶来杀他们。我印象深刻的是人们必须说服自己对方完全是冲着他们来的，一心要摧毁他们，以便迈出走向真正暴力的那一步。
It's not that I think that what happened in Ukraine will happen in America. But talk of violence can become a self-fulfilling prophecy.
并不是说我认为乌克兰发生的事情会在美国发生。但关于暴力的言论可能会成为一种自我实现的预言。
So the stakes for you-- are the stakes just an election? Like, if Trump loses, OK, maybe we can win again in four years?
所以对你来说风险——风险仅仅是一场选举吗？比如，如果特朗普输了，好吧，也许我们四年后能赢回来？
No, I really believe that anybody who gets in after Trump, if they're liberal, is going to be the downfall of America for sure. This election is going to be some sort of a turning point, for good or bad. It's going to be a turning point.
不，我真的相信任何在特朗普之后当选的人，如果他们是自由派，肯定会是美国的灭亡。这场选举将是一个转折点，无论好坏。它将是一个转折点。
Let's roll out.
出发吧。
Calling in.
收到。
It's Tuesday morning, Election Day. Joe and some of his guys are split between two pickup trucks. I'm in the backseat of Joe's. Everyone with me is dressed in battle gear, and they're armed to the teeth. Joe's wearing a bulletproof vest with four or five ammo clips strapped to it and a pistol in a holster.
这是周二早晨，选举日。乔和他的几个手下分乘两辆皮卡车。我在乔的车后座。和我在一起的人都穿着战斗装备，全副武装。乔穿着一件防弹背心，上面系着四五个弹夹，皮套里有一把手枪。
In the passenger seat, Matt, a lanky guy in his 30s, has a big knife strapped to his own body armor in addition to all the ammo clips. And he's wearing a pair of noise-canceling headphones with skulls on them. Both of them have loaded AR-15s in their laps. The plan is to do as the president suggested-- drive to every polling station in their county in Virginia and look for problems. Joe leads the way.
副驾驶座上，马特（Matt），一个30多岁身材瘦长的家伙，除了所有弹夹外，身上还绑着一把大刀。他戴着一副有骷髅标志的降噪耳机。他们膝盖上都放着装满子弹的AR-15。计划是按照总统建议的那样——开车去弗吉尼亚州县里的每一个投票站查看问题。乔带路。
So we're just looking for any signs of people up to no good, possibly trying to deter people or intimidate anybody.
所以我们只是在寻找任何不怀好意的人的迹象，可能试图阻止人们或恐吓任何人。
I'd asked earlier what kind of people they were looking for, and Joe said thugs. When I asked what that meant, he said people from Black Lives Matter, from Antifa. I wasn't sure how he'd know whether a person was a member of a group like that or whether there were even that many of them in this part of the country.
我之前问过他们寻找什么样的人，乔说暴徒。当我问这意味着什么时，他说来自“黑人的命也是命”和“反法西斯主义者”的人。我不确定他怎么知道某人是否是那种组织的成员，或者在这个国家这一部分是否有那么多人。
Well, first of all, Antifa would be dressed in all black, probably. BLM would be just-- they would have all kinds of BLM signage and things like that.
嗯，首先，反法西斯主义者可能会穿全黑衣服。黑人的命也是命的人会是……他们会有各种黑人的命也是命的标语之类的东西。
We pull up to a polling station and sit in a parking lot. Just out there in the open, there are people milling around and then a bunch of guys with guns just watching them.
我们停在一个投票站，坐在停车场里。就在露天的地方，有人在走动，然后一群拿着枪的家伙在看着他们。
You want to pull and change location to right over here by that white vehicle and the picnic shelter?
你想换个位置到那辆白色车辆和野餐凉棚旁边吗？
Yeah, I was just thinking that. Sounds good. Go ahead and move.
是的，我也正有此意。听起来不错。继续移动。
Doug, the gray man, gets ready to go in. He's in his 40s with a beard. He also has an easy demeanor, which is probably the reason they picked him for the job. He's wearing jeans, a fleece, and sunglasses. And you'd have to look closely to notice that there's a wire running down from the back of his hat, which is connected to a radio so he can be in touch with the guys. We hang back in the pickup while Doug goes in. After a few minutes, he casually walks back to us.
灰人道格（Doug）准备进去了。他40多岁，留着胡子。他的举止轻松，这可能是他们选择他担任这份工作的原因。他穿着牛仔裤、抓绒衣和太阳镜。你必须仔细观察才能注意到有一根电线从他的帽子后垂下来，连接到无线电上，这样他就能和伙伴们保持联系。我们在皮卡里等着，道格进去了。几分钟后，他随意地走回我们这里。
So what did you see there?
那么你在那里看到了什么？
Just people talking. There's probably 40 voters in there. More people showing up all the time. Everybody was in a good mood, cheerful. Just looked around, come back out, made a 360 sweep of the building, outside of the building.
只是人们在交谈。那里可能有40名选民。一直有更多人出现。大家心情都很好，很开朗。环顾四周，走出来，对建筑物外围进行了360度扫视。
Nothing at all that was suspicious?
完全没有可疑的地方？
Nothing, no.
没有，没有。
And we're back on the road, with Joe leading the way. At pretty much every polling station, when Doug walks in, this is how it goes.
我们又回到了路上，乔带路。几乎在每一个投票站，当道格走进去时，都是这样的。
Howdy, howdy. How are y'all?
嘿，你们好吗？
Come on over this way, guys.
过来这边，伙计们。
I've already voted earlier today.
我今天早些时候已经投过票了。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
I'm just here checking everything out.
我只是过来查看一下。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
Thank y'all.
谢谢你们。
You're welcome.
不客气。
Most of the day is driving, driving and waiting, waiting and driving. It's a big county spread across winding mountain roads. We drop in and out of cell service, and sometimes Joe gets turned around when his Google Maps goes on the fritz. Matt, the guy in the passenger seat, is good at filling the idle time. He's ready to sound off on just about anything.
这一天大部分时间都在开车、开车和等待、等待和开车。这是一个横跨蜿蜒山路的广阔县。我们时有时无地进入手机信号覆盖区，有时乔的谷歌地图出故障时，他会走错路。副驾驶座上的马特很擅长填补闲暇时间。他随时准备对任何事情发表意见。
I don't know if y'all have watched The Sopranos, but Tony used this-- I mean, the definition of a narcissist.
我不知道你们有没有看过《黑道家族》，但托尼用了这个——我的意思是，自恋者的定义。
He talks about cars.
他谈论汽车。
If I had to pick one muscle car, I would probably go with either '69 Charger RT or the '71 Hemi 'Cuda.
如果我必须选择一辆肌肉车，我可能会选69年的Charger RT或者71年的Hemi Cuda。
The good old days.
美好的旧时光。
Like, we used to argue about like football, talk shit about sport. People don't even do that anymore. They're arguing about this or that or whatever.
就像，我们过去经常争论橄榄球，谈论运动的垃圾话。人们现在甚至不那样做了。他们在为这个或那个争论。
His love handles.
他的腰部赘肉。
Even as skinny as I am, they like to pop out outside.
即使我这么瘦，它们也喜欢跳出来。
Yeah, they don't freaking want to go away either.
是啊，它们真的不想消失。
No, dude, it's just like--
不，伙计，这就像——
Man, I've been working out like crazy. I eat right. I don't do a lot of sugar and nothing like that, but.
伙计，我一直在疯狂锻炼。我吃得也很健康。我不怎么吃糖之类的东西，但是。
The confrontation they suited up for never happens. We don't see Antifa or Black Lives Matter or anyone blocking the polls or intimidating voters or committing fraud. At our last stop, we do see someone lingering outside a polling station. I walk up to the entrance with Doug and see a woman sitting nearby. She's an older white woman with a bag that has a blue sticker for Mark Warner, a Democratic senator. Doug walks right by her with a polite hello, and then we're inside having another awkward conversation with the poll workers.
他们全副武装准备的对抗从未发生。我们没有看到反法西斯主义者或“黑人的命也是命”或任何人阻挡投票、恐吓选民或进行欺诈。在最后一站，我们确实看到有人在投票站外逗留。我和道格走到入口处，看到一位坐在附近的女士。她是一位年长的白人女性，带着一个带有民主党参议员马克·华纳蓝色贴纸的包。道格礼貌地问候了一声便从她身边走过，然后我们进去和投票工作人员进行了又一次尴尬的谈话。
Hello, how are y'all?
你好，你们好吗？
Nice to meet you. Y'all had a pretty good turnout today?
很高兴见到你。你们今天投票率很高吧？
There's been a huge turnout evidently everywhere, which is great.
显然到处都有很高的投票率，这很好。
Good deal.
太好了。
Yeah, people should vote, right?
是啊，人们应该投票，对吧？
Yes, ma'am. Absolutely.
是的，女士。绝对是。
When we walk back outside, the woman is still there. And I notice her eyeing Doug, a little suspicious that he walked in and out so quickly. She asks him if he needs help.
当我们走回外面时，那位女士还在那里。我注意到她盯着道格看，有点怀疑他为什么进进出出得那么快。她问他是否需要帮助。
I've already voted. I was just talking to some people. [CHUCKLES]
我已经投过票了。我只是在和一些人聊天。[轻笑]
Doug goes back to the car, and I decide to go and talk with the woman. She's Janet Tate, a die-hard local Democrat. She says she comes here every election to hand out campaign literature. She's allowed to do that just outside the white line on the pavement. Like a lot of people, Janet had been anxious about being out on Election Day.
道格回到车里，我决定去和那位女士交谈。她是珍妮特·泰特（Janet Tate），一名坚定的当地民主党人。她说她每次选举都来这里发放竞选资料。她被允许在人行道上的白线外这样做。像许多人一样，珍妮特对选举日出来感到焦虑。
I'm pleasantly surprised. My daughter was worried about me a little bit, but I'm like-- I'm old, and I just-- I think it's important.
我感到惊喜。我女儿有点担心我，但我心想——我老了，我只是——我认为这很重要。
I mentioned that I saw her watching Doug.
我提到我看到她盯着道格。
But he was a little odd when he comes kind of zooming in and out. But he was nice.
但他进进出出时确实有点奇怪。但他很友善。
This group is a militia group, actually.
其实这个小组是一个民兵组织。
Oh, they were pretty nice. [LAUGHS] I said they were nice.
哦，他们还挺友好的。[笑] 我说他们很友好。
Joe and the heavily-armed guys in the car are probably exactly the kind of people her daughter was worried about. But Janet tells me she's not going to be intimidated.
乔和车里那些全副武装的家伙可能正是她女儿担心的人。但珍妮特告诉我她不会被恐吓。
I'm like, what are they going to do? Shoot me? My daughter really was worried. Like, don't do it. So.
我想，他们能做什么？开枪打我吗？我女儿确实很担心。比如，别去。所以。
She thought maybe a group like that would--
她想也许像那样的组织会——
Well, she just didn't know what to think, so-- but I-- I don't know. I'm not going to live in a country that I feel uncomfortable going to my polling place and doing normal democratic things. It's like, I could bring my bear spray. [LAUGHS] It just seems ridiculous.
嗯，她只是不知道该怎么想，所以——但我——不知道。我不想住在一个让我觉得去投票站做正常的民主行为都感到不舒服的国家。就像，我可以带上防熊喷雾。[笑] 这看起来太荒谬了。
I head back to the truck. I tell Joe that the woman I was talking to is a local Democrat and that she told me Doug seemed like a nice guy. He's really struck by that. He jumps out of the truck, still in his full battle gear, and suddenly determined to meet her.
我回到卡车上。我告诉乔，我刚才交谈的女士是当地的民主党人，她说道格看起来是个好人。他真的被触动了。他跳下卡车，依然全副武装，突然决定去见她。
So I just want to come and shake your hand. I really appreciate you being out here and helping these people that come out here.
所以我想过来和你握个手。我真的很感谢你来到这里，帮助这些出来的人。
Oh, thank you.
哦，谢谢你。
And I mean, obviously, we're, like, two opposite sides. But I think it's great that people who have differing views can be civil and just get along.
我的意思是，显然，我们像是两个对立面。但我认为有不同观点的人能够文明相处并和睦相处，这很棒。
Right! I mean, I've been doing this since 2007. Yeah.
对！我的意思是，我从2007年就开始这么做了。是啊。
Cool.
酷。
And there's usually--
通常有——
If Janet's intimidated by Joe with his body armor and ammo clips and pistol, she doesn't show it.
如果珍妮特被身穿防弹衣、带着弹夹和手枪的乔吓到了，她没有表现出来。
Well, yeah, we've been kind of patrolling around all day, so.
嗯，是的，我们整天都在巡逻，所以。
I think it's a little excessive, but-- [LAUGHS]
我觉得这有点过分了，但是——[笑]
They talk for a few minutes. He's so big, but Janet just smiles and looks him in the eyes. She even picks an argument with him about the electoral college. At the end, they do a little high five.
他们谈了几分钟。他很高大，但珍妮特只是微笑并直视他的眼睛。她甚至还和他争论关于选举人团的问题。最后，他们击了个掌。
A little off. I'll do better.
有点偏了。我会做得更好。
Let's do better. There you go. That's better. All right. Good deal. All right, we're going to head out of here. You enjoy the rest of your night.
让我们做得更好。在那儿。那更好。好了。太棒了。我们要离开了。祝你余下的夜晚愉快。
Oh, thank you.
哦，谢谢。
When Joe gets back to the car, I notice that he's energized by the encounter. It was the only time of the day I saw him drop his warrior persona. "Great day," he tells me.
当乔回到车里时，我注意到他被这次邂逅激发了活力。这是我一天中唯一一次看到他放下勇士的面具。他告诉我，“美好的一天”。
Not long afterwards, the guys packed it up and went home. They had found no evidence of fraud, no intimidation or disruption. And they never got a chance to protect the vote or engage the enemy. And it was a relief to see that this was totally fine with them.
不久之后，这些人收拾行李回家了。他们没有发现欺诈、恐吓或破坏的证据。他们从未有机会保卫选票或与敌人交战。看到这对他们来说完全没问题，我感到如释重负。
The next day, I called Joe. It was Wednesday. The news was moving towards a Biden victory, and President Trump was already crying fraud. Joe was, too.
第二天，我打电话给乔。那是周三。新闻正朝着拜登获胜的方向发展，特朗普总统已经在高喊欺诈。乔也是。
Up till right now, I'm not very happy with what I'm seeing. Honestly, I think the other side is trying to introduce false ballots into the system. And then they're just going to try to rig it and make it so that Biden wins.
到目前为止，我对所见所闻很不高兴。老实说，我认为另一方正试图向系统中引入虚假选票。然后他们只是要试图操纵它，让拜登获胜。
What makes you think that they're doing that?
是什么让你认为他们在这样做？
There is some fishy stuff going on up there in Michigan and a couple other places that they should have already called for Trump, but they haven't.
密歇根州和其他几个地方发生了一些鱼腥味的事情，他们本应早已宣布特朗普获胜，但他们没有。
The president has been pushing unsubstantiated claims of election rigging in Michigan and other crucial states.
总统一直在推动关于密歇根州和其他关键州选举舞弊的未经证实的说法。
So if it ends up being that Biden is declared the winner, do you think there could be a way that you could just say, yeah, that's probably what happened and believe it?
所以如果最终拜登被宣布为获胜者，你认为有没有可能你会说，是的，这可能就是发生的事情并相信它？
Absolutely not.
绝对不可能。
No chance?
没机会？
Yes, no chance. From everything that we saw and experienced leading up to the election, there is no way that Trump would lose a fair election. There is no way.
是的，没机会。根据我们选举前所见所经历的一切，特朗普不可能输掉一场公平的选举。不可能。
Your own experience yesterday was that you guys checked on the polling stations and everything was running smoothly and you didn't see any fraud.
你们昨天的亲身经历是你们检查了投票站，一切运行顺利，你们没有看到任何欺诈。
No, honestly. Because the fact that people were able to go and cast their vote unimpeded doesn't really have anything to do with what goes on with those ballots and stuff after the people go and cast them.
不，老实说。因为人们能够不受阻碍地去投票这一事实，与人们去投票后那些选票和东西发生的事情真的没有任何关系。
Joe tells me he's sure that if Biden wins, some kind of violence is inevitable. He says they'll end up fighting someone. Black Lives Matter, Antifa-- he's not sure.
乔告诉我他确信如果拜登获胜，某种形式的暴力是不可避免的。他说他们最终会与某人战斗。“黑人的命也是命”、反法西斯主义者——他不确定。
What if, at some point, Trump were to concede and say he accepts that Biden is the president now? Could he change your mind?
如果特朗普在某个时刻承认失败并说他接受拜登现在是总统了会怎样？他能改变你的主意吗？
Absolutely not.
绝对不可能。
Mike Giglio-- he wrote about his experiences covering civil wars overseas in his book Shatter the Nations.
迈克·吉格里奥——他在自己的书《粉碎国家》中写过他在海外报道内战的经历。
Act Two, New York and Germany. So four years ago, the day after Donald Trump won that election, reporter Stephanie Foo met two army officers at a diner to talk to them about their new boss. Those guys were in the same unit, close friends. But they did not agree on politics at all.
第二幕，纽约和德国。四年前，唐纳德·特朗普赢得那场选举后的第二天，记者斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）在一家餐馆见了两名陆军军官，和他们谈论他们的新老板。那两个人来自同一个部队，关系密切。但在政治上他们完全不同意。
Why do you like each other?
为什么你们互相喜欢？
I don't know. Why do we like each other?
我不知道。为什么我们互相喜欢？
We disagree on almost everything.
我们几乎在所有事情上都有分歧。
You know why? Because I know that he'll have my back and I'll have his. Regardless of what he believes-- although it's ill founded, most of it-- yeah, he's awesome. I'd give my life for him.
你知道为什么吗？因为我知道他会支持我，我也会支持他。不管他相信什么——尽管它是毫无根据的，大部分是——是的，他很棒。我会为他献出生命。
I'd save my own life. No. [LAUGHS] He knows we're good.
我会保住自己的命。不。[笑] 他知道我们没问题。
At the time, they went back and forth about what they thought the next four years were going to be like with President Trump as commander in chief. Whether it meant they were more likely to be deployed to a conflict zone, how it would affect morale, and the possibility that Donald Trump might start a nuclear war.
当时，他们讨论了他们认为唐纳德·特朗普作为三军统帅未来四年会是什么样子。这是否意味着他们更有可能被部署到冲突地区，它会如何影响士气，以及唐纳德·特朗普可能发动核战争的可能性。
He'll be fine. He's not going to drop nukes on people.
他会没事的。他不会对人投掷核弹。
I don't know. I think he's incredibly uneducated about it.
我不知道。我认为他对此非常缺乏教育。
So here's the thing about the codes that people don't realize. It's not like he has a piece of paper in his pocket. It's like, oh, here are the nuclear codes. It doesn't work that way.
关于核代码，人们没有意识到的一点是。并不是说他口袋里有一张纸。就像，哦，这里是核代码。它不是那样工作的。
The guy who liked President Trump said the officer with the nuclear football would prevent Donald Trump from randomly nuking somebody. The Hillary Clinton supporter was not so sure. Anyway, Stephanie checked in with two of them again earlier this week. One of them is in the States. One of them is stationed in Germany.
那个喜欢特朗普总统的家伙说，拿着核足球的军官会阻止唐纳德·特朗普随机核打击某人。希拉里·克林顿的支持者则不太确定。无论如何，斯蒂芬妮本周早些时候再次与他们联系。其中一人在美国。另一人驻扎在德国。
The biggest thing that happened to these guys in the last four years actually had nothing to do with Trump. They both had babies.
过去四年里这些家伙身上发生的最大事情其实与特朗普无关。他们都有了孩子。
This is actually better. I can hear you guys pretty good. Sorry I'm late. Somebody decided to take off their diaper and chew on it. So we were dealing with that. And now we're terrible parents. He's crying hysterically because how dare we not let him eat his own feces. So.
这其实更好。我能听清你们说话。抱歉我迟到了。有人决定脱掉尿布并嚼它。所以我们一直在处理那个。而现在我们是糟糕的父母。他因为我们怎么敢不让他吃自己的粪便而歇斯底里地哭泣。所以。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
God, he reminds me of you so much already.
天哪，他现在就让我想起你了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I know. Well, don't worry. Your daughter's not too far behind, uh, Tom.
我知道。好吧，别担心。你的女儿离你也不远，汤姆（Tom）。
These aren't their real names, but Chet and Tom voted exactly how I expected them to in this election. Tom voted for Biden. Chet again voted for Trump. But in 2016, Chet had been a really hardcore Trump supporter. He really wanted an outsider. But now that the outsider is an insider, he feels more agnostic.
这些不是他们的真名，但切特（Chet）和汤姆在这次选举中的投票方式正是我预料的。汤姆投给了拜登。切特再次投给了特朗普。但在2016年，切特曾是一个非常铁杆的特朗普支持者。他真的很想要一个局外人。但既然这个局外人现在成了局内人，他感觉更不可知论了。
And maybe a little part of his indifference is because of Trump's role as their boss. Like the time Trump made the comment saying, why are we having all these people from shithole countries coming here? Chet wasn't crazy about that. Neither was Tom, the Biden supporter, who was deployed in Africa when that went down.
也许他的一点冷漠是因为特朗普作为他们老板的角色。比如特朗普评论说，我们为什么还要让那些来自“屎坑国家”的人来这里？切特对此并不疯狂。拜登的支持者汤姆也不是，当这件事发生时，他正被部署在非洲。
His comments about shithole countries definitely impacted my job. The US military has training exercises across the world with partners. I happened to be in a position at the time where I was running a group of teams that were in African countries. And as you're sitting there, planning for these training events, these comments come out. And it's just like, your partners are kind of like, is this what you guys think about us? So it's--
他关于“屎坑国家”的评论确实影响了我的工作。美国军方在世界各地有与合作伙伴的联合训练演习。我当时恰好处于指挥一个在非洲国家工作的小组的位置。当你坐在那里，策划这些训练活动时，这些评论冒了出来。这就像，你的合作伙伴有点像是，这就是你们对我们的看法吗？所以它——
What did you have to tell them?
你不得不告诉他们什么？
I basically talked through it. That doesn't represent US military's position on our partnerships. And honestly, sometimes it comes down to just bullshitting and having friendly relations with folks.
我基本上谈论了它。那不代表美国军方在伙伴关系上的立场。老实说，有时这归结为只是胡扯并与人们保持友好关系。
Yeah, I've had similar experiences, too. I'm a Trump supporter, right? MAGA 2020. But yes, it does make your job more difficult. I'm not going to defend the fact that when he says something, it's like, OK, it's time to brace.
是的，我也经历过类似的事情。我是特朗普的支持者，对吧？MAGA 2020。但是的，它确实让你的工作变得更困难。我不会为他说话时就像是，好吧，是时候保持警惕了，这个事实辩护。
They weren't totally unhappy with his performance. Both Chet and Tom agreed that Trump's strongman personality did come in handy sometimes. They liked that he engaged with North Korea and supported the assassination of Iranian general Qassem Soleimani. But the thing that's affected them the most during the last four years is the same thing we've all dealt with-- the thing that isn't going to magically go away, no matter who wins.
他们对他的表现并非完全不满意。切特和汤姆都同意特朗普的强人性格有时确实派得上用场。他们喜欢他与朝鲜接触并支持暗杀伊朗将军卡西姆·苏莱曼尼。但过去四年里对他们影响最大的事情与我们所有人经历的一样——无论谁获胜都不会奇迹般消失的事情。
I feel like the thing that's very clear to me is that it really feels like there are two Americas right now.
我觉得对我来说很清楚的一件事是，真的感觉现在有两个美国。
Yeah, sure.
是的，确实。
Does it feel that way in the military?
在军队里感觉是那样吗？
Yes. Oh, yeah.
是的。哦，是的。
That's Chet.
那是切特。
I have colleagues on both sides. And it's awkward.
我有双方的同事。这很尴尬。
Like you used to talk about it more and now people don't want to talk about politics at all?
就像你们过去更多谈论它，而现在人们根本不想谈论政治了？
Yeah, when I went to Iraq in 2008, it was like-- people would be like, I'm voting for Obama, or people were like, I'm going to vote for McCain. But there wasn't any charged racism attached to it. Like, you weren't a racist if you voted for McCain. You could talk about it and nobody would get offended.
是的，2008年我去伊拉克时，就像——人们会说，我投奥巴马，或者人们会说，我要投麦凯恩。但并没有伴随任何带有种族的指控。就像，如果你投麦凯恩，你不是种族主义者。你可以谈论它，没有人会感到被冒犯。
And now, it's just like-- you know. Apparently, I'm a supremacist because I vote for Trump, according to some people. You know what I mean? So I'm just very much like, whatever, man. I'm voting for who I want to vote for. You can do the same. I don't want to talk about it, you know?
而现在，它只是——你知道。显然，我是至上主义者，因为我投了特朗普，根据某些人的说法。你明白我的意思吗？所以我非常像是，随便吧，伙计。我投我想要的票。你也可以做同样的事。我不想谈论它，你知道吗？
One of the moments that bugs Chet the most is from his last deployment. One of his friends was a Black woman who absolutely hated Trump. And she hated all of the white Trump supporting soldiers around her, too. She did hang out with Chet. He thinks it's because he's Asian-American.
让切特最困扰的时刻之一来自他的最后一次部署。他的一个朋友是一位非常讨厌特朗普的黑人女性。她也非常讨厌她周围所有的白人特朗普支持士兵。她确实和切特在一起。他认为这是因为他是亚裔美国人。
And it just put me in an awkward position all the time. And I would always get asked by both sides, like, why are you hanging out with them? And I'd be like, really, man? We're all on the same team. Who cares?
这总是让我处于尴尬的境地。我总是被双方问到，比如，你为什么要和他们在一起？我会说，真的吗，伙计？我们都在同一个团队。谁在乎呢？
Tom agrees. He says that in the military, the mindset should be that there is an enemy, and it's out there, hiding in a cave in Afghanistan somewhere, not in the next aisle at the Stop and Shop.
汤姆表示同意。他说在军队里，心态应该是有一个敌人，它就在外面，藏在阿富汗的某个洞穴里，而不是在Stop and Shop的下一个通道里。
When I was watching the stuff on the news with the Black Lives Matter protest and National Guard troops were getting called in, I kept thinking-- I'm like, that is the worst fucking job. I would never, ever want to do that, right? These are people from your community, and you're getting called in to do something. No one in the military wants to do this.
当我看着新闻中关于“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动以及国民警卫队被召集时，我一直在想——我想，那是该死的最糟糕的工作。我永远、永远都不想那样做，对吧？这些人来自你的社区，而你被召集去做某事。军队里没有人想这样做。
No.
不。
Unless, again, when it comes to emergency situations, I think everybody's all for volunteering to do that in the case of, say, a hurricane. But nobody wants to go in and try and be a policeman. That's not our job.
除非，同样，当涉及到紧急情况时，我认为在比如飓风的情况下，大家都很支持自愿去做。但没有人想进去试图当警察。那不是我们的工作。
No.
不。
I don't know. I follow some military Instagrams, and one of them is like, I killed people in Afghanistan. I'll kill these people today, you know? I mean--
我不知道。我关注了一些军事Instagram，其中一个像是，我在阿富汗杀过人。我今天也会杀了这些人，你知道吗？我的意思是——
I think those people are full of shit.
我认为那些人满嘴胡话。
Idiots. Those people probably failed their psych exam.
白痴。那些人可能心理测试不及格。
A lot of international relationships have been tested by the Trump presidency, but not Chet and Tom's.
特朗普总统任期考验了许多国际关系，但没有考验切特和汤姆的。
You guys are still friends.
你们仍然是朋友。
Yeah. I mean-- but to be totally honest, that's because we have a toxic friendship where we just make fun of each other the whole time. So this is just one more thing we can--
是的。我的意思是——但老实说，那是因为我们有一种有毒的友谊，我们整个时间都在取笑对方。所以这只是我们可以做的另一件事——
Yeah, we've--
是的，我们有——
We can do.
我们可以做。
Yeah. We hated each other long before Trump even decided to run for president. So I mean, we just built on top of that hatred. And now we have this hate mountain over the friendship bridge. It's really a beautiful thing.
是的。在特朗普决定竞选总统之前很久我们就讨厌对方。所以我的意思是，我们只是在那层仇恨之上又加了一层。现在我们在友谊桥上有了这座仇恨之山。这真是一件美妙的事情。
[LAUGHS] OK, guys.
[笑] 好了，伙计们。
Tom says that the military creates an environment where people have to trust and communicate with each other, even if you don't like each other, which is not an attitude America seems to have these days about our democracy. I talked to them Wednesday the day after the election. Tom said he'd be pretty horrified if Trump won. Chet just shrugged. If Biden wins, he said, basically, whatever. Both said they'd respect either outcome.
汤姆说军队创造了一种环境，人们必须信任并与彼此沟通，即使你不喜欢对方，而这似乎不是当今美国对我们民主的态度。我周三在选举日后和他们谈过。汤姆说如果特朗普获胜他会感到非常恐惧。切特只是耸了耸肩。如果拜登获胜，他说，基本随便吧。两人都说他们会尊重任何结果。
Stephanie Foo-- she used to be a producer on our program. She's now writing a memoir about healing from complex PTSD. Coming up, somebody who thought his life was going to change a lot depending on who becomes president, though, now, it's not so clear. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
斯蒂芬妮·富——她曾是我们节目的制作人。她现在正在写一本关于从复杂PTSD中康复的回忆录。接下来，一位认为他的生活会因谁成为总统而发生巨大变化的人，尽管现在还不那么清楚。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Squeaker." I don't know if I should admit here how many minutes today we spent arguing over whether to call the episode "Electile Dysfunction." "Squeaker" was our classy choice.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“险胜”。我不知道我是否应该承认今天我们花了多少分钟争论是否将这一集命名为“选举功能障碍”。“险胜”是我们的优雅选择。
Anyway, our show this week is stories from all over about this strange week we've all just lived through, waiting for election results. Of course, for some people, the outcome of the presidential election might have a very direct effect on their lives.
无论如何，我们这周的节目是来自各地的故事，讲述我们刚刚经历的这个奇怪的一周，等待选举结果。当然，对于一些人来说，总统选举的结果可能会对他们的生活产生非常直接的影响。
Take, for instance, the people living in the tent camp that's just over the border from Texas, in Matamoros, Mexico. A camp filled with people seeking asylum in the United States who'd been sent there under the president's remain-in-Mexico policy. On election night, they held a vigil all night long until 5:00 in the morning.
例如，住在得克萨斯州边境马塔莫罗斯的帐篷营地里的人们。一个挤满了在总统的“留在墨西哥”政策下被送到那里的寻求美国庇护的人的营地。在选举之夜，他们通宵守夜直到凌晨5点。
Apparently, the pastors who put this together tried to keep it apolitical, stick with prayers and songs. But by the end of the vigil, in the early morning hours, the last pastor who took the stage said the thing that apparently lots of them had been thinking all night. He said, "I hope Joe Biden wins." And somebody who was there said it was like everybody finally had a chance to let out their feelings. They cheered. They danced. They've heard Joe Biden promise to reform immigration in his first 100 days in office.
显然，组织这一切的牧师试图保持无党派，坚持祈祷和歌唱。但在守夜结束时，在凌晨时分，最后一个登上舞台的牧师说了显然他们整晚都在想的事情。他说：“我希望乔·拜登赢。”在场的一个人说，这就像每个人终于有机会释放他们的感受。他们欢呼。他们跳舞。他们听到乔拜登承诺在他的任期前100天内改革移民制度。
Which brings us to Act Three. Act Three, Louisiana. Ben Calhoun has this story of somebody else who's not from this country, who's been following the election as closely as he can.
这把我们带到了第三幕。第三幕，路易斯安那州。本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）有另一个人的故事，他不是这个国家的人，一直在尽可能密切地关注选举。
Jonathan, who was in an ICE detention center in Louisiana, told me that this year's presidential race actually solved the problem in the detention centers he's been in. He's been moved around to a few. Jonathan told me the recurring problem was with the TVs. Take the ICE detention center I called him in. It was this small triangular room, he said.
乔纳森（Jonathan），他在路易斯安那州的一个移民及海关执法局（ICE）拘留中心，告诉我说今年的总统竞选实际上解决了他在住过的拘留中心的问题。他被转移了好几个。乔纳森告诉我，反复出现的问题是电视。让我打给他所在的那个ICE拘留中心。他说那是一个三角形的小房间。
Yeah, it's a small triangle room attached to the dorm that, if you want to watch TV, get into that room and watch TV.
是的，那是附属在宿舍上的一个三角形小房间，如果你想看电视，就进那个房间看电视。
The problem with the detention center TVs, though-- well, sort of the same with any TV in America-- people can't agree what to watch. Should we watch English TV? Should we watch Spanish TV?
然而，拘留中心电视的问题——好吧，和美国任何电视一样——人们无法就看什么达成一致。我们应该看英语电视吗？我们应该看西班牙语电视吗？
Should there be time for news? Should there be time for music? Should there be time for football? Should there be time for fun program? So it's another conflict, that problem.
应该有新闻时间吗？应该有音乐时间吗？应该有足球时间吗？应该有娱乐节目时间吗？所以这是另一个冲突，那个问题。
Jonathan told me, during the 18 months he's been in ICE detention, one of the few times this wasn't an issue at all was the presidential debates this fall. Everyone, Jonathan said, wanted to see those.
乔纳森告诉我，在他被ICE拘留的18个月里，这不是问题的少数几次之一就是今年秋天的总统辩论。每个人，乔纳森说，都想看那个。
I called Jonathan the week before the election because I wanted to talk to someone in our immigration system whose case could potentially be affected by it. I wondered how the election looked from where they were.
我在选举前一周给乔纳森打了电话，因为我想和移民系统中的某个人谈谈，他的案件可能会受到影响。我想知道从他们所在的位置看选举是什么样的。
Jonathan said he'd talked to other detainees about the election. He'd been talking to guards, too. Most of them, he told me, were Biden supporters. But yeah, lots of people were wondering how the election might change their cases, including him. Jonathan's 30. He's from Cameroon. And he came to the US in 2019 seeking asylum. He's been stuck in detention ever since.
乔纳森说他和其他被拘留者谈过选举。他也和警卫谈过。他告诉我，他们大多数人都是拜登的支持者。但是是的，许多人想知道选举可能会如何改变他们的案件，包括他。乔纳森30岁。他来自喀麦隆。他于2019年来到美国寻求庇护。从那以后他一直被困在拘留所。
I think all that boils down to the administration of the foreign government. So based on the information and what I'm seeing, personal-- from my own personal point of view-- if Biden could win, hopefully, I think it will be better.
我认为这一切归结为外国政府的行政管理。所以根据信息和我所看到的，个人——从我个人的角度来看——如果拜登能赢，希望，我认为会更好。
Under President Trump, asylum seekers like Jonathan are getting deported, even ones with strong evidence that they're political refugees who will be tortured or killed if they return to their home countries. Jonathan-- I should tell you, that is not his real name. I'm calling him that because he has family back in Cameroon, and he has good reason to worry about their safety.
在特朗普总统领导下，像乔纳森这样的寻求庇护者正在被驱逐，即使是有强有力的证据表明他们是如果返回祖国就会被折磨或杀害的政治难民。乔纳森——我应该告诉你，那不是他的真名。我这样称呼他是因为他在喀麦隆有家人，他有充分的理由担心他们的安全。
Jonathan is part of an English-speaking minority that's been persecuted by Cameroon's French-speaking majority and its longtime autocratic president, Paul Biya. That whole situation has gotten more and more violent. Jonathan wasn't part of that. He was a businessman, a grocery wholesaler. He bought stuff from farmers to sell in town. And he started the business to support his mom after his dad died.
乔纳森是一个讲英语的少数群体的一部分，该群体一直受到喀麦隆讲法语的多数群体及其长期独裁总统保罗·比亚（Paul Biya）的迫害。整个局势变得越来越暴力。乔纳森不是那一部分。他是一个商人，一个食品批发商。他从农民那里买东西在城里卖。他开办这家企业是为了在父亲去世后支持他的母亲。
Basically, Jonathan got caught in the wrong place at the wrong time. He was in this barber shop when it got raided by soldiers. He and 14 others got thrown in jail, and they were beaten and tortured for nearly a month. At one point, a few men were taken out, and they never came back. And the soldier told the rest of them that they were all going to get killed.
基本上，乔纳森在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。他在这个理发店时，它被士兵突袭了。他和另外14人被扔进监狱，他们被殴打和折磨了近一个月。有一次，几个人被带走，再也没回来。士兵告诉剩下的其他人他们都会被杀。
Then, one day-- a warning, this is pretty graphic. One day, an officer took Jonathan and one other man at gunpoint, and he led them outside to a truck. He told them to clean it up. And Jonathan looked inside it.
然后，有一天——预警，这非常生动。有一天，一名军官用枪指着乔纳森和另外一个人，把他们带到外面的一辆卡车前。他让他们打扫它。乔纳森向里面看去。
You see stains of blood, stains of blood, which likely will be human beings-- human beings and chopped particles.
你看到血迹，血迹，很可能是人类——人类和碎裂的颗粒。
Jonathan says there was blood all over the inside, particles of flesh. He started to clean. And then at some point, he noticed that the soldier was distracted and talking to someone.
乔纳森说里面到处都是血，肉的颗粒。他开始打扫。然后在某个时刻，他注意到士兵分心了，在和某人说话。
When I have that window of opportunity. I said I will rather be killed while I'm trying to save my life than to stay and be killed.
当我有了那个机会窗口。我说我宁愿在我试图挽救生命时被杀，也不愿留下来被杀。
Jonathan says he slipped around the corner of the building. And then he ran through a cornfield, and he just kept running. Eventually, he got to a cousin's house and then eventually escaped to Ecuador.
乔纳森说他滑到了建筑物拐角处。然后他穿过玉米地跑了，他只是不停地跑。最终，他到了一个堂兄弟的家里，然后最终逃到了厄瓜多尔。
I just want to say Jonathan's account of all these details, it's all well supported by documents and photos and legal affidavits. Among the documents, there's a warrant for Jonathan's arrest for, quote, "terrorism, secession, and insurrection." Jonathan told me if the government gets its hands on him, chances he'll be killed are 100%. That's what he said-- 100%.
我只想说乔纳森关于所有这些细节的叙述，都有文件、照片和法律宣誓书的充分支持。在这些文件中，有一份对乔纳森的逮捕令，理由是“恐怖主义、分裂主义和暴动”。乔纳森告诉我，如果政府抓到他，他被杀的几率是100%。那是他说的——100%。
Jonathan's attorney told me, under a different presidential administration than President Trump's, he thinks his asylum case would have a much better shot. So after escaping, Jonathan went through nine countries. At some point, someone gave Jonathan a piece of advice that would end up being really important. They said rip your passport up. It will make it harder for anyone to send you back to Cameroon. So Jonathan did that.
乔纳森的律师告诉我，在不同于特朗普总统的总统任期下，他认为他的庇护案件会有好得多的机会。所以逃跑后，乔纳森穿过了九个国家。在某个时刻，有人给了乔纳森一个最终非常重要的建议。他们说把你的护照撕了。这会让任何人更难把你送回喀麦隆。所以乔纳森那样做了。
In the end, he made it to the US. He made it into ICE custody. I asked Jonathan why he didn't seek asylum in any of the other nine countries. And he told me it was simple. He didn't know enough about any of those other countries to know if they would protect him or if they'd send him back.
最后，他到了美国。他进入了ICE的拘留。我问乔纳森为什么他不寻求在其他九个国家中的任何一个寻求庇护。他告诉我说这很简单。他对比那些国家了解得不够多，不知道他们是否会保护他，或者他们是否会把他送回去。
All I know-- to be frank, what I know about United States, I know a country that can protect your human rights. That's one best thing that I know about-- that I knew before coming, that it's a country that protects human rights. It was a county that I believed will protect me. I was taking the option because all I need was just protection. All I need was just protection.
我所知道的——坦率地说，关于美国，我知道一个可以保护你人权的国家。这是我在来之前知道的最好的事情——这是一个保护人权的国家。这是一个我相信会保护我的国家。我选择那个选项是因为我所需要的只是保护。我所需要的只是保护。
A judge ordered Jonathan to be deported. The only reason he and his lawyer thought he hadn't been is because Jonathan had taken that advice and destroyed his passport back in Panama. For months, ICE officers had been asking Jonathan to sign this document that would apparently let them send him back to Cameroon. Jonathan has been refusing, telling them that he'll be tortured and killed.
法官下令将乔纳森驱逐出境。他之所以没有被驱逐，唯一的理由是他和他的律师认为乔纳森听取了那个建议并在巴拿马毁掉了他的护照。几个月来，ICE官员一直要求乔纳森签署一份显然让他们可以把他送回喀麦隆的文件。乔纳森一直拒绝，告诉他们他会被折磨和杀害。
ICE, in response, told Jonathan they would hold him in indefinite detention until he signed. And ICE, for their part-- well, they started leaning on Jonathan harder and harder. You have to sign this. Recently, he told me that situation came to a head when an ICE agent he knew led him into a room.
ICE回应说，在乔纳森签署之前，他们将无限期拘留他。而ICE，就他们而言——好吧，他们开始越来越严厉地施压乔纳森。你必须签这个。最近，他告诉我说，当他认识的一名ICE特工把他带进房间时，情况到了紧要关头。
He said he is not going to listen to anything from me. His job is for me to sign this and for him to send me back to my country.
他说他不会听我的任何话。他的工作是让我签这个字，让他把我送回我的国家。
Jonathan got on his knees and begged. Said he'd be killed. The officer wasn't hearing it. He said he needed a picture of Jonathan signing. So he repeated.
乔纳森跪下哀求。说他会被杀。军官没听进去。他说他需要一张乔纳森签字的照片。所以他重复了。
And he told me his job is for me to sign this thing and for me to take the photo. So he even tried to grab my hand for the other person to take a photo of me. So I was pleading. I cried. I knelt down. He should not do this to me.
他告诉我他的工作是让我签这个东西，让我拍照。所以他甚至试图抓住我的手，让另一个人拍我的照片。所以我恳求。我哭了。我跪下了。他不应该对我这样做。
He grabbed your hand.
他抓住你的手。
Yeah, he tried to grab my arm to take a photo.
是的，他试图抓住我的胳膊去拍照。
All of this only stopped, Jonathan says, when a female officer opened the door and asked what was going on. She called the other officers over to her, and they talked where Jonathan couldn't really hear them. Then he was allowed to go call his lawyer.
所有这一切只有在一名女警官打开门问发生了什么事时才停止。她把其他警官叫到她那里，他们在乔纳森听不到的地方谈话。然后他被允许去给他的律师打电话。
After Jonathan and I talked, we agreed that he would call me the day after the election at 5:00 PM. I wanted to hear his reaction to whatever results or non-results we'd have by then. But that never happened. Because the morning after the election, when everyone was waking up to a map with eight states still suspended and gray, I got a voicemail from Jonathan's lawyer.
在乔纳森和我谈话后，我们同意他将在选举后的第二天下午5点给我打电话。我想听到他对那天我们可能有的任何结果或非结果的反应。但这从未发生。因为选举后的第二天早上，当每个人醒来看到一张仍有八个州悬而未决和灰色的地图时，我收到了乔纳森律师的语音留言。
Yeah, hi, Ben. It's Ruth. They've moved him somewhere. I don't know where. I have no idea where. I can't get ahold of anybody at ICE or the Correctional Center. Anyway, I'm going to be busy trying to find him. I'll talk to you later. Bye.
是的，你好，本。我是鲁思。他们把他转移到某个地方了。我不知道在哪里。我完全不知道在哪里。我联系不上ICE或惩教中心的任何人。无论如何，我要忙着找他了。回头再聊。再见。
Ruth Hargrove, Jonathan's lawyer, couldn't find him. She'd woken up the morning after the election to see four missed calls on her phone.
鲁思·哈格罗夫（Ruth Hargrove），乔纳森的律师，找不到他。她在选举后的第二天早上醒来，发现手机上有四个未接来电。
It was this morning at 5 o'clock in the morning, but I don't know why I missed it. But then his aunt called me and said he was being moved. And--
是今天早上5点，但我不知道为什么我错过了。但他姑姑给我打电话说他正被转移。而且——
Ruth told me the day before, Election Day, Jonathan told her about this unusual incident where ICE had taken him in to identify his belongings at a property room. And they asked about his sponsor-- which, he's got an aunt in Maryland who's offered to take him in while he tries to get asylum. Jonathan told Ruth he was hopeful that that's what was up, that he was finally getting out.
鲁思告诉我，前一天，选举日，乔纳森告诉她关于这次不寻常的事件，ICE带他去物业室认领他的财物。他们询问了他的担保人——他在马里兰州有一位姑姑愿意在他试图寻求庇护时收留他。乔纳森告诉鲁思他很有希望那是怎么回事，他终于要出去了。
But Ruth was suspicious. She'd gotten this email from an activist group about a deportation flight to Cameroon on November 10. She'd been getting increasingly nervous that Jonathan might get put on it. And so that morning, after the election, when Jonathan was just removed from the Louisiana detention center, Ruth started scrambling, just trying to figure out where exactly he was, where he was going. When we talked, she was still reeling.
但鲁思很怀疑。她收到一个激进组织关于11月10日飞往喀麦隆的驱逐航班的电子邮件。她越来越紧张乔纳森可能被送上飞机。所以那天早上，选举后，当乔纳森被从路易斯安那州的拘留中心移走时，鲁思开始疯狂尝试弄清楚他到底在哪里，他在去哪里。当我们谈话时，她仍然感到震惊。
OK, so-- and I just found out-- I think he's on his way to a staging facility in Alexandria, Virginia-- not Virginia, Louisiana. And that's a big staging area for flights out.
好的，所以——我刚刚发现——我想他正在去弗吉尼亚州亚历山大市的集结设施的路上——不是弗吉尼亚，路易斯安那。那是飞往外地的很大一个集结区。
Ruth told me she was trying every legal avenue she could think of. She hadn't confirmed it 100% from ICE that Jonathan was being deported, but she was increasingly sure. It had to be that, she thought.
鲁思告诉我她正在尝试她能想到的每一种法律途径。她没有从ICE那里100%确认乔纳森正在被驱逐，但她越来越确定。她认为一定是那样。
Before I play you this last piece of tape, I need to tell you a few things about Ruth. She's no softy. She's a former prosecutor. She's the wife of a former Navy SEAL and DEA agent. OK, but so, the first time we talked, she told me she had this kind of big worry around the election and around Jonathan. She was worried that even if Joe Biden won, the Trump administration officials would go on a scorched earth sort of tear with detainees like Jonathan and that he'd be deported as part of that.
在我播放最后一段录音之前，我需要告诉你一些关于鲁思的事情。她不是个软弱的人。她是一位前检察官。她是前海豹突击队成员和缉毒局探员的妻子。好吧，所以，我们第一次谈话时，她告诉我她在选举前后和乔纳森周围有这种大担忧。她担心即使乔·拜登获胜，特朗普政府官员也会对像乔纳森这样的被拘留者进行焦土政策，他会作为其中的一部分被驱逐。
This is what-- this is what I thought was going to happen, actually. And I don't know if I told it to you or to someone else. (VOICE QUAVERING) But the way I think of these people is that they didn't have confidence that Trump was going to win. Maybe-- I think maybe they were wrong. [SNIFFLES] Then once he goes back, then I can't save him.
这就是——这就是我以为会发生的事情，实际上。我不知道我是告诉了你还是告诉了别人。（声音颤抖）但我对这些人的看法是，他们对特朗普会赢没有信心。也许——我想也许他们错了。[抽泣] 然后一旦他回去，我就救不了他了。
If I could get a hearing here, if I could get him a fair hearing in front of a fair judge, he would be found to have suffered terrible persecution and to have been in great danger of future persecution. And you only have to show there's a 10% chance that he'll have a future persecution.
如果我能在这里进行听证会，如果我能给他一个在公平法官面前的公平听证会，他会被发现遭受了可怕的迫害并且处于未来迫害的巨大危险中。你只需要证明他有10%的几率未来会遭受迫害。
But there's a warrant for his arrest, and the government has it. And they're going to-- they'll be there. And the ICE officer I talked to last time I thought he was going to be deported when I said he has an arrest warrant for him, he said, oh, yes, he has an arrest warrant. The military will be there waiting for him at the airport. I mean, they know. They know.
但有一份对他的逮捕令，而政府手里有。他们会——他们会在那儿。我上次和ICE官员交谈时，我以为他会被驱逐，当我提到他有逮捕令时，他说，哦，是的，他有逮捕令。军队会在机场等着他。我的意思是，他们知道。他们知道。
Thursday, as election results were still gathering in news headlines, I got a call from Jonathan, who was in a detention center in Texas. And he filled me in on what had happened. The morning after the election, he told me, an ICE officer came to see him around 5:00 AM and told Jonathan to take his stuff. They were going to the airport. Jonathan says he begged him the whole way there. Told him that if he was deported, he would be killed.
周四，当选举结果仍在新闻头条中汇总时，我接到了乔纳森的电话，他在得克萨斯州的一个拘留中心。他告诉我发生了什么。选举后的第二天早上，他说，一名ICE官员在凌晨5点左右来看他，告诉乔纳森带上他的东西。他们要去机场。乔纳森说他一路哀求。告诉他如果他被驱逐，他会被杀。
At the airport, he told me, he resisted. He refused to get out of the vehicle. But the officers dragged him onto a plane, which took him and some other Cameroonians to Texas. He was told he would be there for a few days, unclear how many, but that he was there to be deported.
在机场，他告诉我，他反抗了。他拒绝下车。但警官把他拖上了飞机，把他和其他喀麦隆人带到了得克萨斯州。他被告知他会在那里待几天，不清楚几天，但他被送到那里是为了被驱逐。
I contacted ICE about Jonathan's situation. In a statement, a spokesperson said, he'd been, quote, "afforded extensive legal processes and was ultimately found by a federal judge to have no legal basis to remain in the United States," end quote. They declined to give any information about when he might be deported, though an ICE officer confirmed to Ruth that Jonathan would be on a plane early next week.
我联系了ICE关于乔纳森的情况。在一份声明中，一位发言人说，他“获得了广泛的法律程序，并最终被联邦法官裁定没有留在美国的法律依据”。他们拒绝提供关于他何时可能被驱逐的任何信息，尽管一名ICE官员向鲁思证实乔纳森将在下周初登上一架飞机。
Before I got off the phone with Jonathan on Thursday, I asked him if he knew what would happen if he arrived in Cameroon. He said he'd been trying to reach relatives who might be able to help him. I have no idea what awaits me, he said. He just kept repeating that. He told me, other than talking to his lawyer, Ruth, and trying to reach family for help, he'd been spending all of his time praying.
在周四我挂断乔纳森的电话之前，我问他是否知道如果他到达喀麦隆会发生什么。他说他一直在尝试联系可能能够帮助他的亲属。我不知道有什么在等着我，他说。他只是不停地重复。他告诉我，除了和他的律师鲁思交谈并试图联系家人寻求帮助外，他把所有时间都花在祈祷上。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Four, Detroit. In a bunch of cities around the country this week, Republicans have congregated in election centers where votes are being tallied, protesting, chanting for the counting to stop, or, in the case of Arizona, where President Trump is behind the vote count, chanting for the counting to continue.
第四幕，底特律。这周全国各地的许多城市，共和党人聚集在计票的选举中心，抗议，高喊停止计票，或者在特朗普总统落后于计票的亚利桑那州，高喊继续计票。
We wondered what it would be like to be inside one of those counting rooms trying to do your job with all that chaos going on outside. Emanuele Berry talked to a woman who was inside the vote counting room in Detroit when Trump supporters tried to get inside, chanted, banged on the windows.
我们想知道在所有那些外面的混乱中，在那些计票室里试着做你的工作是什么感觉。埃曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）采访了一位当特朗普支持者试图进入、高喊、拍打窗户时，身处底特律计票室的女士。
Khalilah Gaston lives in Detroit. She's a news junkie. For this year's presidential election, she kept thinking she'd volunteer. And on Tuesday night, she saw her chance, a Facebook post asking for poll watchers to watch the counting of mail-in ballots in Detroit. It was at a big convention center.
哈利拉·加斯顿（Khalilah Gaston）住在底特律。她是新闻迷。今年总统选举，她一直在想她会做志愿者。周二晚上，她看到了机会，脸书上的一篇帖子请求投票观察员在底特律观察邮寄选票的清点。那是在一个大型会议中心。
On Wednesday morning, she goes through training. Then she walks into the room where there are 134 tables where votes are being processed. She's assigned a partner and an aisle of tables to watch.
周三早上，她通过了培训。然后她走进有134张桌子正在处理选票的房间。她被分配了一位搭档和一条桌子通道进行观察。
And even though it was my first time, I was like, I'm in the game. So you gotta-- and I actually heard these two Trump supporters say that. They said democracy is a contact sport. And if you're not in the game, then you can't complain in the outcome. You can't complain if you don't win. And so as a former athlete, for me, I was like, OK, it's game time, you know?
即使这是我第一次，我还是想，我在比赛中。所以你必须——我实际上听到了那两个特朗普支持者说了那样的话。他们说民主是一项接触运动。如果你不在比赛中，那么你就不能抱怨结果。如果你不赢，你就不能抱怨。所以作为一名前运动员，对我来说，我当时想，好的，比赛时间到了，你知道吗？
Each state has their own rules for poll watching. In Michigan, Republicans and Democrats are allowed to have one challenger per table. Challengers can challenge a ballot. And then there are also poll watchers, like Khalilah, who cannot challenge votes or ballots, but can observe the counting.
每个州都有自己的投票观察规则。在密歇根州，共和党和民主党被允许每张桌子有一名挑战者。挑战者可以质疑选票。然后还有像哈利拉这样的投票观察员，他们不能质疑投票或选票，但可以观察计票。
And honestly, it's all pretty tame. Khalilah stands on the side of the room, looking around, taking notes, raising small concerns with supervising staff, like if a person isn't wearing their mask properly. That's how her day starts out. She's just one of hundreds of people in a room watching hundreds of other people count ballots. But a couple hours in, things change.
老实说，这一切都很温顺。哈利拉站在房间一侧，环顾四周，做笔记，向主管人员提出小小的关切，比如如果有人没戴好口罩。她的一天就是这样开始的。她只是房间里数百人中的一个，观察数百个其他人清点选票。但过了几个小时，事情变了。
Around, I want to say, between 11:00 and 12:00, that's when I noticed really just a shift in the climate in the room. People started-- yeah, some people started just getting more chippy.
大约，我想说，在11点到12点之间，那时我真的注意到了房间氛围的变化。人们开始——是的，有些人开始变得更挑衅。
Most of the Republican poll watchers were doing their job without issues. But a handful of them started to become disruptive.
大多数共和党投票观察员在做他们的工作而没有问题。但其中少数开始变得具有破坏性。
I saw with my own eyes, at my table where I was, berating people as they were handling ballots. They were being asked what their political party was. And these were election workers who were handling ballots. Are you a Democrat? Are you a Republican? I saw people challenging ballots before they even got to the table, so making blanket statements. I'm challenging every ballot at this table. And it's like, well, there's no ballots at the table.
我亲眼看到，在我所在的桌子上，当人们处理选票时，他们辱骂人们。他们被问及他们的政党是什么。而这些是处理选票的选举工作人员。你是民主党人吗？你是共和党人吗？我看到人们在选票甚至还没到桌子上之前就质疑选票，所以做笼统的声明。我质疑这张桌子上的每一张选票。就像，好吧，桌子上没有选票。
She was told this might happen in training, that people may cause a scene or try and distract or slow down vote counting.
在培训中她被告知这可能会发生，人们可能会制造现场或试图分散注意力或减慢计票速度。
I think for me, it was very emotional at a certain point. I saw a lot of colleagues, a lot of friends, a lot of elders in our community who were there. And so for me, seeing elders of our community, people who had dedicated eight years to do this, being berated and physically intimidated by, in a lot of instances, younger white people, right, the optics were very disconcerting. You also had people in there talking about their Second Amendment rights. And so eventually, people started to be escorted out of the room.
我认为对我来说，在某个时刻它是非常情绪化的。我看到了很多同事，很多朋友，很多我们社区的长辈也在那里。所以对我来说，看到我们社区的长辈，那些致力于做这件事八年的人，被在很多情况下更年轻的白人辱骂和身体恐吓，对，景象非常令人不安。你那里也有人谈论他们的第二修正案权利。所以最终，人们开始被护送出房间。
At this point, Joe Biden was starting to take the lead in Michigan. And there were growing rumors and disinformation spreading online about election fraud in Detroit. More poll watchers showed up in the lobby, demanding to be let into the counting room. The building officials refused, saying they had too many people in there already, including over 500 Republican and Democratic poll watchers.
在这一点上，乔·拜登开始在密歇根州领先。网上流传着关于底特律选举欺诈的谣言和虚假信息。更多投票观察员出现在大厅，要求被允许进入计票室。大楼官员拒绝了，说里面已经有太多人了，包括500多名共和党和民主党投票观察员。
Even more people gathered outside the building. And what you ended up with was a group of mostly white people, chanting, "stop the vote, stop the count," in a city of mostly Black voters. The thing that I have thought about over and over again during this election cycle is that Black people exercising their political will is seen as cheating.
大楼外聚集了更多人。而你最终得到的是一群主要是白人，高喊“停止投票，停止计票”，在一个主要是黑人选民的城市。在整个选举周期中，我反复想过的一件事是，黑人行使他们的政治意志被视为作弊。
Just this Thursday, the president called two cities with large Black populations, Detroit and Philadelphia, quote, "two of the most corrupt political places anywhere in our country" with no evidence for this at all, and declared that these cities, quote, "cannot be responsible for engineering the outcome of a presidential race."
就在这个周四，总统称两个拥有大量黑人人口的城市，底特律和费城，引用“我们国家任何地方最腐败的两个政治场所”，完全没有任何证据，并宣布这些城市，引用“不能负责设计总统竞选的结果”。
Wednesday afternoon at the convention center, as the crowd outside kept getting bigger, Khalilah wasn't aware of any of it. She wasn't near the windows. But then things slowed down at her tables, and she took a stroll.
周三下午在会议中心，当外面的人群越来越大时，哈利拉没有意识到这一切。她不在窗户附近。但后来她桌子上的事情慢了下来，她去散步了。
I walked to the front by the media pen, and that's when I saw literally a man climbing the windows. I saw people screaming, pushing on the doors. And one of my close friends was there checking in observers and challengers. And she was just really overwhelmed.
我走到媒体区前面的地方，那时我看到字面意义上有一个人在爬窗户。我看到人们尖叫，推门。我的一位亲密朋友在那里登记观察员和挑战者。她真的非常不知所措。
And then later on, you could feel it. You could feel and you could see the window shaking while we were in there. And--
然后后来，你能感觉到它。我们就在里面，你能感觉到也能看到窗户在摇晃。而——
What did you think might happen?
你认为可能会发生什么？
My worst fear was-- I hope, one, no one opens the door. Are they going to try to force us to stop counting the vote? Are they going to try to physically harm us? Are people armed? I mean, we're in Michigan, right, where you had people storm the State Capitol with guns just a month earlier, right? You had members of the militia-- you know, a plot uncovered to try to kidnap our governor.
我最大的恐惧是——我希望，第一，没有人开门。他们会试图强迫我们停止清点选票吗？他们会试图在身体上伤害我们吗？人们持有武器吗？我的意思是，我们在密歇根州，对吧，一个月前你那里有人拿着枪冲进州议会大厦，对吧？你有民兵成员——你知道，一个被揭露的试图绑架我们州长的阴谋。
Khalilah was concerned about what was happening outside. But she had another feeling as she was standing there watching people inside-- pride. They all just kept working, kept counting the votes. Around 7:00 PM, Khalilah headed home. She felt relieved to be done. But Thursday--
哈利拉担心外面发生了什么。但当她站在那里看着里面的人时，她有另一种感觉——自豪。他们所有人只是继续工作，继续清点选票。大约晚上7点，哈利拉回家了。她感到如释重负。但周四——
This morning when I woke up, I just busted out crying. And I was like, what? What just happened? It was like, why all of that emotion? And it took me a minute. And I was like, that was traumatic, right? What occurred last night was traumatic.
今天早上我醒来时，我只是大哭起来。我就想，什么？刚发生了什么？就像，为什么会有那种情绪？我花了一分钟。我就想，那是创伤，对吧？昨晚发生的事情是创伤。
But trauma isn't the main feeling Khalilah took away from this experience. She feels emboldened. She says she's definitely going to poll watch again.
但创伤不是哈利拉从这次经历中带走的主要感觉。她感到备受鼓舞。她说她肯定会再次观察投票。
Emanuele Berry is the executive editor of our show.
埃曼纽尔·贝里是我们节目的执行编辑。
Act Five, Miami. So maybe this is going to be the year when everybody gets the memo that Latino voters are not an actual thing. They're not a voting bloc with shared interests and identities and political affiliations who all vote the same. This year, Mexican-Americans in Arizona put the state within reach of the Democrats for the first time since the '90s.
第五幕，迈阿密。所以也许今年每个人都会收到拉丁裔选民不是一个真实事物的备忘录。他们不是一个具有共同利益、身份和政治倾向的选民集团，他们不会都投同样的票。今年，亚利桑那州的墨西哥裔美国人自90年代以来第一次让该州触及民主党人。
Meanwhile, on the other side of the country, Cuban-Americans and Venezuelans helped seal the deal of President Trump's victory in Florida. And then there's the generational split. Young Latinos tend to be more liberal than their parents. Nadia Reiman talked to a family like that, a mother and son from Miami. They're Venezuelan, and they're split.
与此同时，在国家的另一边，古巴裔美国人和委内瑞拉人帮助锁定了特朗普总统在佛罗里达州的胜利。然后是代际分歧。年轻的拉丁裔往往比他们的父母更自由。纳迪娅·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）谈到了一个那样的家庭，来自迈阿密的一对母子。他们是委内瑞拉人，他们分开了。
When I asked Marco and his mom Ninotchka how often they talked about politics, they were like, oh, it's a topic.
当我问马尔科（Marco）和他的母亲尼诺奇卡（Ninotchka）他们谈论政治的频率时，他们像是，哦，这是个话题。
(SUBJECT) NINOTCHKA [SPEAKING SPANISH]
（主体）尼诺奇卡 [说着西班牙语]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说着西班牙语]
A lot. "We actually invite it," they say. Which can be tricky, because Marco voted for Biden and Ninotchka for Trump. They're part of that Venezuelan voting bloc in Florida that the press has been freaking out about, wondering why, oh, why would Latinos-- as if we were one thing-- vote for Trump?
很多。“我们实际上邀请它，”他们说。这可能很棘手，因为马尔科投给了拜登，尼诺奇卡投给了特朗普。他们是佛罗里达州媒体一直在恐慌的那部分委内瑞拉选民集团的一部分，想知道为什么，哦，为什么拉丁裔——就好像我们是一样的一样——会投给特朗普？
The family moved to Miami 20 years ago. They all still live together. Marco and Ninotchka actually work together at her accounting firm.
这个家庭20年前搬到迈阿密。他们仍然住在一起。马尔科和尼诺奇卡实际上在她会计事务所一起工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说着西班牙语]
Marco tells his mom, because of Venezuela, I already knew you were going for Trump. Because Biden didn't come out hard against Maduro and Venezuela's socialist government. Ninotchka also says Biden flirted-- her words-- with Cuba too much, and that was all a deal breaker for her, too close to communism. She can't even say Venezuela's former president's name, Hugo Chavez. She called him [SPANISH] which is-- and I'm not even exaggerating-- "he who must not be named," like Voldemort.
马尔科告诉他的妈妈，因为委内瑞拉，我早就知道你要投给特朗普。因为拜登没有严厉反对马杜罗和委内瑞拉的社会主义政府。尼诺奇卡也说拜登——她的词——和古巴调情太多，那对她来说也是交易破坏者，太接近共产主义了。她甚至不能说出委内瑞拉前总统的名字，乌戈·查韦斯（Hugo Chavez）。她称他 [西班牙语]，那是——我甚至没有夸张——“那个不能说出名字的人”，就像伏地魔。
Ninotchka really wants you to know, though, that she didn't vote for Trump. She voted for the Republican Party. She doesn't like him-- at least, not a lot. She thinks he's really rude about immigrants, which she thinks is hypocritical, given that his wife is an immigrant. She thinks he's arrogant. She also told me she hated the way he treats reporters, though I'm aware she said this to a reporter.
然而，尼诺奇卡真的想让你知道，她没有投给特朗普。她投给了共和党。她不喜欢他——至少，不喜欢很多。她认为他在移民问题上真的很粗鲁，鉴于他的妻子是移民，她认为这很虚伪。她认为他傲慢。她还告诉我她讨厌他对待记者的方式，尽管我意识到她是对记者说的。
I asked Marco how it made him feel that his mom voted for Trump. He squirmed. He moved his hands a lot, avoided eye contact.
我问马尔科，他母亲投给特朗普让他有什么感觉。他扭动着身体。他手势很多，避免目光接触。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说着西班牙语]
It's a mess, he says. It's a mental and emotional mess. I feel strange. I don't want to say "betrayed."
这简直是一团糟，他说。这在心理上和情感上都是一团糟。我感觉很奇怪。我不想说“背叛”。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说着西班牙语]
He's like, damn. I know other friends and other parents who also came here because of politics, also from Venezuela, and they went for Biden. And so it makes me think, what did these other parents find out that made them make a different decision, one that's more like mine? He said his mom's vote made him feel a little ashamed.
他像是，该死。我认识其他因为政治也来到这里的朋友和其他父母，也来自委内瑞拉，他们投给了拜登。所以这让我思考，这些其他父母发现了什么导致他们做出不同的决定，一个更像我的决定？他说他妈妈的票让他感到有点羞耻。
Ninotchka does not even get a little upset about this. She's like socialism, honey. You didn't live through it.
尼诺奇卡甚至没为此感到一点不安。她像是社会主义，亲爱的。你没有经历过它。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说着西班牙语]
She says, it's like you have a scar, and it doesn't get erased. And it still hurts, and it won't close up. How are you going to understand if you haven't lived it, she tells me. How is he going to get it if he hasn't lived it either? She points at Marco. But those of us who have lived it always feel it here, she says, and she points at her heart, and here, and she points at her head.
她说，这就像你有一道伤疤，它不会被抹去。它仍然很痛，而且不会闭合。你怎么会理解如果你没有经历过它，她告诉我。如果他也没有经历过，他怎么会明白？她指着马尔科。但我们这些经历过的人总是能感觉到它在这里，她说，她指着她的心，以及这里，她指着她的头。
I asked her if she thought the people who were scared about Trump, who think he may be the start of a regime itself, like fascism, if she thought they were wrong. She said no. She said she could see it. But that still seemed so far away and unreal, compared to the socialism she did live through. One was a possibility. The other was already a reality.
我问她是否认为那些害怕特朗普的人，认为他可能是政权本身开端的人，比如法西斯主义，如果她认为他们是错的。她说不。她说她能看到这一点。但相比她确实经历过的社会主义，那似乎仍然太遥远和不真实。一个是可能性。另一个已经是现实。
And then, just as we were wrapping up the interview, she said, we got to just wait calmly for results. And honestly, for the good of the country, maybe Biden should win. Trump makes people so angry. This surprised me. She had been so clear about not wanting Biden. But when she unpacked it a little more, I understood. She doesn't want unrest. That, she knows very well. She knows how that story ends.
然后，就在我们结束采访时，她说，我们只能冷静地等待结果。老实说，为了国家的好，也许拜登应该赢。特朗普让人太生气了。这让我很惊讶。她对不想要拜登表现得非常清楚。但当她更多地拆解它时，我明白了。她不想要动荡。那，她很清楚。她知道那个故事是如何结束的。
Nadia Reiman is one of the producers of our show.
纳迪娅·雷曼是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Six, Massachusetts. So one of our producers, Sean Cole, saw some talking head types on CNN recently, discussing the stakes of this year's presidential election and how both Democrats and Republicans see it as "existential." That's the word they used-- "existential." Like, the very existence of our democracy or even our planet hangs in the balance, which-- it can seem kind of abstract.
第六幕，马萨诸塞州。所以我们的制作人之一，肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole），最近在CNN上看到一些谈话头类型的人，讨论今年总统选举的风险以及民主党人和共和党人如何将其视为“存在主义的”。那是他们使用的词——“存在主义的”。就像，我们民主的存在甚至我们星球的存在都悬在平衡中，这——它看起来有点抽象。
In these past few weeks, as we approached Election Day, Sean and somebody very close to him have been dealing with very immediate and real world existential questions. Here's Sean.
在过去几周，当我们接近选举日时，肖恩和一个与他非常亲近的人一直在处理非常直接和真实世界存在的问题。这是肖恩。
About two weeks before the election, my stepfather, Ed, was admitted to Cape Cod Hospital. He was rushed there in an ambulance with extreme shortness of breath, like he was suffocating. It turned out to be lung cancer, a tumor almost the size of a golf ball that caused all this fluid to build up in his left lung, plus a precarious blood clot on the same lung.
选举前大约两周，我的继父艾德（Ed）被送进了科德角医院。他因极度气短被救护车紧急送往那里，就像他快窒息了一样。结果是肺癌，一个几乎像高尔夫球那么大的肿瘤导致所有这些液体积聚在他的左肺，加上同一肺上一个危险的血栓。
I raced up there from New York before even knowing the diagnosis. Ed's 90 and had already been battling stage four prostate cancer for a couple of years. So there's been this ambient sense of waiting for the other shoe to drop.
在甚至知道诊断之前，我就从纽约赶去了那里。艾德90岁了，已经与第四阶段前列腺癌抗争了几年。所以一直有一种等待另一只鞋掉落的环境感。
When I got to the hospital, two nurses were settling him into the room where he'd spend the next four days. One of them asked him a whole battery of standard intake questions. History of smoking? Yes. Do you drink caffeine? Yes. And then she said, do you feel threatened by anyone at home or just in your life? Ed paused, looked down, and said, the president.
当我到达医院时，两名护士正在帮他安置在他将度过接下来四天的房间里。其中一人问了他整套标准的入院问题。吸烟史？是的。你喝咖啡因吗？是的。然后她说，你在家或生活中感到受到任何人的威胁吗？艾德停顿了一下，低下头，说：总统。
I thought that was really funny-- and also telling. Even in this dire moment for him, Trump and the election still kept bobbing back up to the surface. Ed's a Democrat. He follows the news pretty closely. And back when he was merely contending with stage four prostate cancer, he told me several times that he just wanted to live long enough to see what happens with the election. He's had zero existential dread beyond that.
我觉得这真的很有趣——但也很有说明性。即使在他对他来说这个危急的时刻，特朗普和选举仍然不停地浮出水面。艾德是民主党人。他非常密切地关注新闻。当他仅仅在处理第四阶段前列腺癌时，他几次告诉我他只是想活到足以看到选举结果。除此之外，他没有存在性的恐惧。
And at some point during his hospital stay, I realized this was almost certainly going to be Ed's last presidential election. And I wondered if he might be experiencing it differently than the rest of us. So for a couple of my daily hospital visits, I brought my recorder along.
在医院期间的某个时刻，我意识到这几乎肯定是艾德最后一次总统选举。我怀疑他是否可能正在以与我们其他人不同的方式经历它。所以我带上录音机去医院看了几天。
Oh my god, I'll be glad that it'll be the last election.
噢天哪，我会很高兴它是最后一次选举。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Why?
为什么？
Are you kidding? Why? They're such nonsensical things, and people act like assholes-- excuse the expression. I mean, being a Republican has turned into some kind of religion now, and being a Democrat, too. And once again, I have the best position in the house. If Trump wins, I don't care if I die. And if Biden wins, OK, Trump's gone.
你在开玩笑吗？为什么？它们是如此荒谬的事情，人们表现得像混蛋——原谅我的表达。我的意思是，成为共和党人现在变成了一种宗教，成为民主党人也是。再一次，我坐在屋里最好的位置。如果特朗普赢了，我不在乎我是否会死。如果拜登赢了，好吧，特朗普走了。
Do you think you'll make it till the election?
你认为你能撑到选举吗？
Well, I'll be mighty pissed at these doctors if I don't.
嗯，如果我不撑到的话，我会对这些医生非常生气。
At that point-- again, this was more than a week before Election Day-- the doctors still hadn't given him a prognosis about how long he might live. They did tell him that the blood clot could detach at any time and go to his brain or his heart and kill him.
在那一点上——同样，这是在选举日前一个多星期——医生仍然没有给他关于他还能活多久的预后。他们确实告诉他，血栓可能随时脱落并进入他的大脑或心脏杀了他。
He was equally sanguine and philosophical about that as he's been about the cancer. Told me the clot will either kill him or it won't. And if it doesn't, why should he worry? And if it does, he won't be able to worry. He's so placid about his mortality that it doesn't leave a lot of room for me morosely wringing my hands about it when I'm with him.
他对此感到同样乐观和哲学，就像他对癌症的态度一样。告诉我血栓要么杀了他，要么不会。如果不，他为什么还要担心？如果是，他也将无法担心。他对自己的死亡是如此平静，以至于当我和他在一起时，这没有给我留下太多阴郁绞手的空间。
But now there's this kind of gradient from what he's probably still going to be alive for to what he might be, to what he probably won't be. And he doesn't get to choose, of course. But I thought I'd ask him anyway.
但现在有一种梯度，从他可能还能活着的到他可能，再到他可能不会的。当然，他不能选择。但我还是想问他。
How long do you want to be around for? What are the things that you want to see still?
你想要活多久？你想要看到仍然存在的哪些事情？
Well, let's see. Biden will take over. Trump still will be a lame duck president after the election, but still be president. So three months.
好吧，让我们看看。拜登将接管。特朗普在选举后仍将是跛脚鸭总统，但仍然是总统。所以三个月。
Three months, you want to keep going.
三个月，你想要继续。
At least. Maybe two more. I'm not going to commit suicide and-- you know. I'm not going to say I'd like to be around three months, and then four months go by and people say, why are you still alive? That doesn't make any sense, not to me.
至少。也许再两个月。我不会自杀并且——你知道。我不会说我想活三个月，然后过了四个月，人们问，为什么你还活着？这没有任何意义，对我来说。
As long as I'm not in acute pain, I don't mind a little inconvenience to stay alive. There might be a good show on once in a while. Or there might be a good book to read. I mean, I'm not one that wants to live just for the sake of living. I think it's an excellent time, in the next two or three years, to die.
只要我没有剧烈的疼痛，我不介意一点点不便来活下去。偶尔可能会有一个好的节目。或者可能会有一本好书可以读。我的意思是，我不是那种仅仅为了活着而想活着的人。我认为，在接下来的两三年里，是一个死亡的好时机。
Why?
为什么？
You're avoiding all sorts of huge problems. We have global warming coming out big time. The country is still going to be divided, even if Biden wins. And he's got a hell of a time putting it back together, but I think he might. But still, Europe is going totalitarian. This country is going more totalitarian, which is scary. So there's not much to look forward to. Things I would like to see are answers to big questions. Is there intelligent life in this universe that is not on Earth? And I would like to--
你在避免各种巨大的问题。我们有全球变暖大举到来。国家仍然会分裂，即使拜登赢了。他要花很大力气把它重新组装起来，但我认为他可能会。但仍然，欧洲正走向极权。这个国家正变得更加极权，这很可怕。所以没有太多值得期待的事情。我想要看到的事情是对重大问题的回答。这个宇宙中是否有不是在地球上的智能生命？并且我想要——
He went on to talk about this thing he read about possible evidence of life on Venus. As usual, he got excited talking about this stuff, like a kid. I think it's his curiosity that's kept him around this long. The same curiosity-- not partisanship or spite or ghoulish vengefulness, but curiosity-- that's had him wanting to see how the election plays out, which I think is such a pure perspective to watch this whole yucky circus from, especially as he'd be totally forgiven for just changing the channel.
他继续谈论他读到的关于金星上生命可能的证据。像往常一样，他像个孩子一样兴奋地谈论这些事情。我认为是他的好奇心让他活了这么久。同样的好奇心——不是党派偏见或恶意或可怕的报复心，而是好奇心——让他想要看到选举结果，我认为这从一个纯粹的角度来看待整个该死的马戏团，尤其是如果他完全被原谅只是换个频道。
[DIALTONE]
[拨号音]
Hi, son.
嗨，儿子。
Hi, Ed. How are you doing?
嗨，艾德。你好吗？
Fair to middling.
一般般。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
This call was early Friday morning, three days after Election Day. Ed was back home from the hospital with three new prescriptions, including a heavy-duty blood thinner for the clot, which has actually been working. And while almost everyone else I knew was biting their nails, waiting for the electoral scoreboard to change, Ed was not. In fact, on election night itself, he did change the channel. Didn't even watch the returns come in.
这通电话是在周五清晨，选举日三天后。艾德带着三张新处方从医院回到了家，包括一种用于血栓的重型血液稀释剂，这实际上一直有效。虽然我认识的几乎所有人都在咬指甲，等待选举记分牌改变，但艾德没有。事实上，在选举之夜本身，他确实换了频道。甚至没有看结果出来。
No, I watched a Hallmark movie, which you know is scripted. You can always tell the outcome after five minutes.
不，我看了霍尔马克电影，你知道它是剧本。五分钟后你总是能看出结果。
It's like the opposite of this election, basically.
这就像这次选举的相反，基本上。
Yeah. It's like the opposite of a lot of things in life-- most things. What's more interesting than who wins is what happens now.
是啊。这就像生活中许多事情的相反——大多数事情。比谁赢更有趣的是现在发生了什么。
Yeah.
是啊。
It'll be far more interesting. Will the Trump supporters try to look for another person like Trump? Will they try to find a leader? How is Russia going to behave?
它会更有趣。特朗普的支持者会试图寻找像特朗普一样的另一个人吗？他们会试图找到一个领导人吗？俄罗斯会如何表现？
It almost sounds like the script at the end of an episode of a TV show where they give you the cliffhanger. Like, will the dynamic duo escape the clutches of-- find out.
它几乎听起来像一部电视剧集结尾的剧本，他们在那里给你悬念。就像，这对搭档会逃脱谁的魔掌吗——找出答案。
Exactly. And I hope-- for the country's sake, not for mine, because I won't be living that long in the future. So I hope, for the country's sake, that Biden wins.
正是。我希望——为了国家的利益，不是为了我的，因为未来我不会活那么久。所以我希望，为了国家的利益，拜登获胜。
I told Ed there's this thing I've been trying to square. How he can be so at peace with his own mortality, and yet so concerned for the fate of the country and, really, the world he's leaving behind? Those seem like opposites, I said. And he said he didn't see the conflict. Of course he's concerned. Yes, he's not going to be around a lot longer, but we will. And he still cares about that.
我告诉艾德，有一件事我一直在努力理清。他怎么能对他自己的死亡如此平静，而对国家和真正他留下的世界的命运如此关心？我说，这些看起来像是相反的。他说他没有看到冲突。当然他很关心。是的，他不会活太久了，但我们会。他仍然关心那个。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND" BY SHARON JONES & THE DAP-KINGS]
[音乐 - "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND" BY SHARON JONES & THE DAP-KINGS]
Well, our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis and Ben Calhoun. The people who together today's show include Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Noor Gill, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Andrea López-Cruzado, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Lisa Pollak, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry.
好吧，我们的节目今天由达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）和本·卡尔霍恩制作。今天节目的人员包括埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、希拉里·埃尔金斯（Hilary Elkins）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、达米安·格雷夫（Damien Grave）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、安德里亚·洛佩兹-克鲁扎多（Andrea López-Cruzado）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、纳迪娅·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Rose and Steve Johnson, the Rural Utah Project, Kate Groetzinger, Dilianna Bustillos, Vero Cardenas, Harini Krishnan, Janani Ganesh, Ryan Fisher, Grant Rommel, Josh Mendelsohn, Claire Wardle, Lisa Kaplan, Cindy Otis and Sophie Lawton of the Alethea Group, Elena Cryst, Kyle Vass, Lizzy Johnson, Christopher Rhoads, Joe Certaine, Mel D. Cole, Madeline Heim, Tamara Stevens, Jennifer Jordan, Laura Yellig, Zoe Clark, Sarah Hulett, Ursula Luse, Jared Marcelle, and Taylor Armstrong.
今天特别感谢罗斯（Rose）和史蒂夫·约翰逊（Steve Johnson）、乡村犹他项目、凯特·格罗兹辛格（Kate Groetzinger）、迪莉安娜·布斯蒂略斯（Dilianna Bustillos）、维罗·卡德纳斯（Vero Cardenas）、哈里尼·克里希南（Harini Krishnan）、贾纳尼·加内什（Janani Ganesh）、瑞安·费舍尔（Ryan Fisher）、格兰特·罗梅尔（Grant Rommel）、乔什·门德尔松（Josh Mendelsohn）、克莱尔·沃德尔（Claire Wardle）、丽莎·卡普兰（Lisa Kaplan）、辛迪·奥蒂斯（Cindy Otis）和Alethea集团的索菲·劳顿（Sophie Lawton）、埃琳娜·克里斯特（Elena Cryst）、凯尔·瓦斯（Kyle Vass）、莉齐·约翰逊（Lizzy Johnson）、克里斯托弗·罗兹（Christopher Rhoads）、乔·塞坦（Joe Certaine）、梅尔·D.科尔（Mel D. Cole）、马德琳·海姆（Madeline Heim）、塔玛拉·史蒂文斯（Tamara Stevens）、詹妮弗·乔丹（Jennifer Jordan）、劳拉·耶利格（Laura Yellig）、佐伊·克拉克（Zoe Clark）、莎拉·休利特（Sarah Hulett）、厄休拉·卢斯（Ursula Luse）、贾里德·马塞尔（Jared Marcelle）和泰勒·阿姆斯特朗（Taylor Armstrong）。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He does a really bad impression of a kitchen door that's been left open on a windy day. Here he is, Torey.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换传送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他模仿了一个在多风的日子里被敞开的厨房门的拙劣模仿。这就是他，托雷。
Bang, bang, bang, bang.
砰，砰，砰，砰。
Bang.
砰。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week. I wonder if we'll have a president by then. See you soon.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来。不知道到那时我们是否会有总统。很快见。
[MUSIC - "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND" BY SHARON JONES & THE DAP-KINGS]
[音乐 - "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND" BY SHARON JONES & THE DAP-KINGS]